ich hatte es ja eben schon mal gesagt es
geht um die internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
unserer Unternehmen insbesondere das
industriellen Mittelstands der der
exportierenden Industrie und da brauchen
wir einfach Vertrauen in den deutschen
Standort und das ist in Zeiten der
schwersten Energiekrise seit Bestehen
der Bundesrepublik das Thema Nummer eins
wir haben hochlohn Land das ist auch in
gewisser Weise erfreulich dass die
Menschen viele Menschen ordentlich
verdienen wir haben noch eine gute
Infrastruktur naja aber immerhin sie
wird noch geschätzt vielleicht wird sie
zu langsam erneuert wir haben hohe
Steuern hohe Unternehmen steuern das
belastet den Standort jetzt haben wir
die höchsten Energiekosten der Welt und
das können wir uns auf Dauer nicht
erlauben und deswegen sage ich wir
brauchen um die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
deutschen Wirtschaft langfristig zu
stärken nicht nur eine Entlastung bei
den Energiepreisen eben ist schon gesagt
worden wir haben jetzt einen
industriegaspreis von 7 Cent
gaspreisbremse zeitlich befristet aber
vielleicht geht das langfristig wenn wir
belügend LNG Angebote bekommen auch aus
anderen Regionen kanada gehört auch dazu
finde ich wir haben
auf den Weg gebracht eine
strompreisbremse die ist noch nicht
konkretisiert worden das muss in der
nächsten Tagen folgen ganz wichtiges
Signal für die Wirtschaft wir brauchen
perspektivisch meiner Meinung nach auch
ein industriestrompreis das muss ein
anderes Marktdesign geben vielleicht
married order ohne den teuersten muss
man mal gucken wie man das ausgestaltet
aber ich erwarte dass wir als
Perspektive für die deutsche Wirtschaft
auch perspektivisch einen
industriestrompreis bekommen so
Entlastung brauchen wir auch bei den
Steuern das beste Instrument sind dabei
übrigens super Abschreibungen erhöhte
Abschreibungen da steht auch im
Koalitionsvertrag das muss spätestens
2024 auf die Schiene gesetzt werden
Abschreibung sind deswegen besser als
Steuer Wirkungen weil sie sicherstellen
dass die Investitionen hier bei uns
stattfinden und nicht irgendwo auf der
Welt und das dritte
Entlastungspaket das brauchen wir im
Zusammenhang mit der Bürokratie ein
riesiges Paket oh ja wir brauchen viel
schnellere Planung und Genehmigung zu
verfahren kurze Punkte die man sich ganz
komprimiert merken kann super
Abschreibungen in 2024 beschleunigte
Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren
belastungsmoratorium für die Wirtschaft
und industriestrompreis das sind die
Punkte die ich hier auf jeden Fall
fordere Herr fahren heute als ehemaliger
Politiker ja auch das hat ja auch viel
mit Bürokratie zu tun gibt es da
überhaupt eine Chance dass das passieren
wird also dass das geht hat der Grund
welcher dargestellt nicht die LNG
Genehmigung ist innerhalb von drei
Wochen erfolgt und wenn man sozusagen
wir haben gerade über erdgas-fracking in
Deutschland gemacht das könnte man auch
in drei Monaten machen da das heißt also
wir müssen jetzt eigentlich der Politik
klar machen
dass sie das was an Beschleunigung da
ist zum generellen Standard in
Deutschland macht aber da stellen wir
eben doch fest dass ich meine das sagen
wir heute Abend aber das Thema ist nicht
wirklich
eingefühl wirklich in den in den
Ministerien der Regierung angekommen das
ist da ist kein Wille da ich da der
Wirtschaftsminister hat viel zu tun um
in in Saudi Arabien und den in Katar
nicht zu viel gebracht nee eben das das
Erdgas kaputt zu machen muss man ganz
deutlich zu sagen hat den nämlich gesagt
eigentlich wollen wir gar keine Erdgas
langfristig weil wir wollen ja aus dem
Erdgas raus und dann hatten die Kataris
gesagt ja schönen Dank und haben es an
die Italiener vergeben so erfolgreich
war er da und der wird auch nichts tun
um das zu beschleunigen das ist den
Grünen sozusagen nicht nicht geheuer
wenn schnelle Prozesse passieren und Sie
haben ja eine industriefeindlichkeit an
sich deswegen
ich bin auch enttäuscht von den
Verbänden nicht die müssen viel mehr
Druck machen die Gewerkschaften müssen
in Berlin antreten und sagen wir
brauchen jetzt eine Initiative für die
Industrie ich habe selbst eine
Initiative jetzt auf dem Weg gebracht
rettet unsere Industrie das können sie
googeln da können Sie sich einen
Aufkleber an ihr Auto machen ja soweit
kommt das noch weil diese Verbände wie
eine Lehmschicht zwischen den wirklichen
Problemen des Mittelstands stecken und
der Politik und nichts durchlassen und
deswegen brauchen wir das auf jeden
Aufkleber auf jeden auf jedem Auto denn
atomkraft nein danke das war gestern und
jetzt heißt es rettet unseren Wohlstand
rettet die Industrie da mir eigentlich
viele immer große Hoffnungen in FDP sind
sie denn enttäuscht von der FDP ja die
SPD die FDP hat glaube ich sich an ein
Jahr lang einlullen lassen und dafür hat
sie die Quittung in drei Landtagswahlen
bekommen sie hat
furios gestartet hat viele Dinge wie zum
Beispiel die die die Steuererklärung
verhindern
aber dann ist auch nichts mehr gekommen
und da kommt die Quittung und die muss
jetzt sich zum Anwalt der Arbeitsplätze
machen zum Anwalt der Industrie ich
schicke einen Lindner gerne diesen
Aufkleber
vielleicht möchten Sie den Aufkleber
auch haben was sagen Sie jetzt mit dem
Vorwurf dass sie sich ein Jahr lang
haben eindullen lassen
also das kann ich so das teile ich so
nicht
Überraschung gewesen wenn ja schauen sie
werden gerade heute gesprochen über den
Neubau der Talbrücke A45 bei Lüdenscheid
dann riesen 10 Jahre ein
zehn-jahres-thema wäre das normalerweise
gewesen acht bis zehn Jahre war die
Prognose dann hat man gesagt ja wenn man
das machen wenn wir das machen dann
schaffen das vielleicht in fünf Jahren
jetzt sind wir inzwischen bei vier
Jahren und das alles ist sozusagen ich
bin auch nicht sicher ob dass das Ende
der Fahnenstange ist weil ich
optimistisch bin dass wir mit einer
Vertragsausgestaltung wo eine schnellere
Fertigstellung belohnt wird sogar unter
die vier Jahre kommen können also da ist
einiges passiert und das ist gut so und
das verdanken wir den
Wirtschaftsminister Quatsch stimmt
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing er wäre
besser Wirtschaftsminister geworden
nicht das war der frontschifffahrt
heute Abend noch ein lobesbrief
haben wir auch durchgesetzt 48 Millionen
Menschen freuen sich dass sie nächstes
Jahr auf ein weniger Steuern zahlen bzw
die gleichen steuern aber der Kauf
kostet Verlust durch die Inflation
ausgeglichen wird also da ist einiges
möglich es wäre vielleicht mehr möglich
gewesen wenn wir schon mit einem
krisenmodus in die Regierungsarbeit
gegangen werden aber noch mal wir haben
eine Zeitenwende wir haben eine
Zeitenwende seit dem 24 Februar wenn wir
später darüber diskutieren würde ich
sogar sagen wahrscheinlich schon zu
Beginn der Olympischen Winterspiele die
gemeinsame Erklärung von China und
Russland das war für mich eigentlich
schon der Auslöser für die zeitenwände
die wir haben und darauf war niemand
vorbereitet das gebe ich offen zu ja
wenn man sich den Koalitionsvertrag
durchliest was da alles drin steht auch
zu ihren täten Geheimdienste das hat
nichts zu tun mit den Anforderungen den
wir uns Herausforderungen den den wir
uns heute stellen
nachvollziehen dass die Bürger sich
überhaupt nicht mehr abgeholt fühlen sie
hören wie Politiker die Regierungsarbeit
loben während sie sich Angst um ihre
Energiekosten machen wie sie teilweise
ihre mietet sein sollen das Bürger sich
vielleicht allein gelassen fühlen
aktuell
wir haben drei entlassungspakete auf den
Weg gebracht mit einem Gesamtvolumen von
95 Milliarden Euro wir haben mit dem
Abwehrschirm auch einen finanziellen
Rahmen geschaffen von bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro um all die Maßnahmen die
jetzt die Gaspreise eindämmen und auch
die Strompreise annehmen werden zu
finanzieren das ist schon sehr sehr
selbst einkaufen
ja also nicht so nicht zu euch ich nicht
so häufig
das Quark oder Butter kostet würden sie
es wissen nein aber Butter ist deutlich
teurer geworden deutlich aber wenn Sie
den Preis wissen also ich habe immer
einen guten Euro bezahlt das dürfte in
Euro 50 Euro 60 jetzt anführen
ja
ich denke wenn ich ihn einen Tipp geben
darf als Moderatorin gehen sie morgen
meinen Supermarkt einkaufen und schauen
Sie was die Bürger zahlen wenn sie das
machen würdest würde mich sehr freuen
also Inflation ist die größte Bedrohung
für Wohlstand und Arbeitsplätze
weil damit kommen sie nicht mehr hin
wenn wir aber mit der Gießkanne Geld
verteilen dann heizen wir Inflation an
das ist ein Problem dass wir nicht lösen
können mit fiskalischen Maßnahmen das
können wir nur durch höhere
Produktivität in der Wirtschaft und
deswegen fordere ich ja all diese Dinge
die ich gefordert habe damit
Investitionen kommen um die
Produktivität zu steigern um
Arbeitsplätze noch besser zu bezahlen
bezahlen zu können und dann gleichzeitig
bei Steuerentlastung dann kommen wir
dahin dass wir Inflation auch wieder in
den Griff bekommen aber Inflation ist
fürchterlich und sie gehen einkaufen
sie denn was zuletzt das Päckchen Butter
1 Euro oder 1,50 € gekostet hat ist ja
ziemlich lange her also ich kenne die
aktuellen Preise nur 29 das günstigste
Angebot nicht nur dass ich also gut das
ist jetzt vielleicht nicht bei Aldi
sondern ich gehe alles selber machen
45 für Kerrygold gezahlt ja typische
hausfrauentag nicht ja genau
ich denke das ist wichtig weil das ist
ja das ist ein jedes mal selber
schockiert wenn man einkaufen will das
ursprünglichen butterpreises das ist
schon richtig jetzt überall überhaupt
schon mal ein paar Monate gelaufen nicht
von heute auf morgen aber das nützt uns
jetzt nichts die Preise sind
sind nur noch was für wohlhabende
Menschen Herr fahren heute sie selber
haben ja wenn man das so ausdrücken darf
kommen sie aus einfacheren Verhältnissen
als sie heute leben was hätten denn zum
Beispiel ihre Eltern gesagt wenn
Politiker nicht mehr wissen was ein
Päckchen Butter kostet das weiß ich
jetzt nicht das was meine Eltern dazu
gesagt hätten aber ich ich weiß ja wohl
wie sie damals jeden jede mag umdrehen
mussten und deswegen kann ich es auch
gut nachvollziehen und wir Sie wenn man
dann noch von der Politik dann so so
Formel Sprüche hört wie
Waschlappen oder andere Dinge nicht oder
zwei Pullover übereinander ziehen
dann dann fühlt sich die Bevölkerung die
wirklich kämpfen muss die weiß am 20
schon nicht mehr da geht dann dass der
kontokorrentkontritt los ja da geht dann
das Negative Konto los weil das war der
Lohn nicht mehr ausreicht um die
entsprechenden
kostensteiger abzudecken es ist
schrecklich wenn ein Bundesminister sagt
ich weiß nicht wie das der Liter Benzin
kostet das ist das was uns alle jeden
Tag interessiert und da muss man dann
sagen ihr Punkt unser
Landwirtschaftsminister herr Özdemir hat
gesagt wir wollen jetzt eigentlich die
Felder verknappen wir wollen den wir
wollen Lebensmittel weniger Lebensmittel
produzieren indem wir überall
ökologischen Landbau machen und und
Lebensmittel müssen teurer werden das
ist hohen in den Ohren unserer Bürger
und da müsste er mal hinkommen sein tut
mir leid das habe ich alles nicht so
kommen sehen und wir machen jetzt mal
diesen ganzen Unfug nicht mehr im
Augenblick mal sehen dass wir aus jeder
jedem Hektar Land auch wirklich
Lebensmittel bekommen und damit auch
eine Kostendämpfung hinkriegen